It is a quirk of our minds that not every
emotion we carry is fully acknowledged, understood
or even truly felt. There are feelings that
exist in an ‘unprocessed’ form within
us. A great many worries may, for example,
remain disavowed and uninterpreted and manifest
themselves as powerful directionless anxiety.
Under their sway, we may feel a compulsive
need to remain busy, fear spending any time
on our own or cling to activities that ensure
we don’t meet what scares us head on (these
might include internet pornography, tracking
the news or exercising compulsively). A similar
kind of disavowal can go on around hurt. Someone
may have abused our trust, made us doubt their
kindness or violated our self-esteem but we
are driven to flee a frank recognition of
an appalling degree of exposure and vulnerability.
The hurt is somewhere inside, but on the surface,
we adopt a brittle good cheer (jolliness being
sadness that doesn’t know itself), we numb
ourselves chemically or else adopt a carefully
non-specific tone of cynicism, which masks
the specific wound that has been inflicted
on us. We pay dearly for our failure to ‘process’
our feelings. Our minds grow unoriginal from
a background apprehension as to their contents.
We grow depressed about everything because
we cannot be sad about something. We can no
longer sleep, insomnia being the revenge of
all the many thoughts we have omitted to process
in the day. We need compassion for ourselves.
We avoid processing emotions because what
we feel is so contrary to our self-image,
so threatening to our society’s ideas of
normality and so at odds with who we would
like to be. An atmosphere conducive to processing
would be one in which the difficulties of
being human were warmly recognised and charitably
accepted. We fail to know ourselves not out
of laziness or casual neglect; it simply hurts
a lot. Processing emotions requires good friends,
deft therapists and ritual moments like Philosophical
Meditation, in which our normal defences can
safely be put aside and unfamiliar material
ring fenced for investigation. The outcome
of processing our emotions is always an alleviation
in our overall mood. But first we must pay
for our self-awareness with a period of mourning
in which we gradually acknowledge that, in
some area or other, life is simply a lot sadder
than we would want it to be
We publish new thought provoking films every week.
Be sure to subscribe to our channel and take a look at more of what we have to offer at the link on your screen now.